walk'n hello i'm paul cowling with film
independent and welcome to our thursday
coffee talk with robert Eggers before we
start a few words about film independent
if you don't know us we're a member
based organization a non-profit based in
Los Angeles
probably most famous for the film
Independent Spirit Awards but we also
produce monthly screenings panels and
workshops and conversations and those
are open to all maybe ship is open to
all so check us out from independent dog
but today it's all about behind the
scenes of the lighthouse very pleased to
have a guest with us today mr. Robert
Eggers Robert welcome hi thanks for
having me you are currently in London
right I'm in Belfast oh yeah I no longer
have an apartment in New York and I've
been in Belfast prepping my next movie
since November and and when the lockdown
happened because my my son is a toddler
we decided we would just stay here so I
this is not my home this is just like
the guest room in the apartment that
we're living in that I turned into an
office best I can and here we are well
we'd love to know a little bit more
about your new film later on but let's
talk about the lighthouse because it's
one of my favorite movies of last year I
don't know if I could ever see it again
I mean that in the best possible sense
it is a truly intense experience I
highly recommend everyone catch this
film so take us back to the beginning I
imagine after you make the witch you
could do anything you're one of those
lucky people that could do anything they
wanted right what why why this project
well I mean it took many years before
that became the thing that went
developed to larger movies they were
both my own scripts but but even though
I could do anything I wanted I still
didn't have the clout and to make movies
of a certain scale and actually being
control of them the way that I that I
that I wanted so so so some things
didn't happen frankly and and so but but
in the process of developing the two
larger films and also a TV series I
called it my brother Max and I said you
remember this lighthouse movie that we
were working on or talking about many
years ago we should do that because I
need something in my my back pocket and
so then Artie features an a 24 who
worked with me on two which were eager
to do the next thing and New Regency and
had been wanting to find something and
so we all came together and and
strangely the lighthouse was the thing
that went so yeah well I don't want to
get in too much into detail about the
sort of financing and stuff but what I'm
very curious about is kind of how did
you pitch this to a 24 New Regency well
I mean to to reference the lucky
situation that I was in I think that
that they were happy to be like in
business with me or whatever and and and
and I think that they liked the script
and I certainly thought it was strange
but also exciting but I I always make
elaborate look books with my scripts
which give an idea of what the visuals
are and generally the finished film is
quite close to these look books and so
they knew kind of visually what what it
would look like to to a degree so I mean
I mean there wasn't much of a pitch
really I think I think there was
convincing to do it on thirty
five-millimeter
black-and-white negative there was some
convincing there and there was also some
full-frontal like male nudity like and
like an erection and they were kind of
like look it can be black and white and
and we heard and all this stuff but I
can't be rated nc-17 and I thought that
was very fair okay I think I think if
you're gonna go make the lighthouse you
you know that you're making something
that is hard to describe right and also
shooting in a cat it's not Academy is it
it's a slightly different so it's a
slightly it slightly narrower than
Academy it's 119 to one sometimes called
Movietone it's it was a early film early
sound film aspect ratio and and Jerry
and Blaschke the DP suggested it kind of
as a joke but initially but I thought it
was a great idea because it has it
really does take you to the past in a
way that even is more extreme than
Academy or and and and then additionally
you know it's it's good for shooting
vertical objects like lighthouse towers
and conveying the cramped interior
spaces and it's a great aspect ratio for
close-ups as well but it's a phobia
right yeah yeah if you can get an
widescreen like the Wolves this year
here yeah right yeah and that wasn't it
was like it the easy sell for you
Regency they were they were fine about
that I think like ten days before we
went into production I did get a phone
call kind of asking are you sure you
want to do this I've seen the location
it's so like beautiful and sure you
don't want it if you didn't why is it
screening maybe it's too fussy and I
explained for like 30 or 40 minutes why
I needed to be in asked that aspect
ratio and talking about the history of
painting in western art and you know and
canvases not being in CinemaScope and
like and so on and so forth and finally
they just wanted to get off the phone so
yeah so I wanted to rewind a little bit
because I know they think that the germ
of the story started with your brother
writing a modern-day night house set
drama right and yang took it over and
decided to subtitle it back to the late
1890s yeah why that era and I mean did
you know a lot about that era about the
1890s yeah I mean it's like I think that
there's so many films and books that are
celebrated and in it's sort of the turn
of the century the sort of you know late
Victorian and early an Edwardian era
like so and and also growing up in in
New England
most of the antiques that are around are
kind of from that period so yeah it was
it was something that I I'm quite
familiar with I didn't know a ton about
lighthouses but basically the reason why
I settled on that period was because I
wanted a for now lens which is the lens
in the beacon of the White House that
magnifies the light before for now
lenses it was a series of concave
mirrors behind lanterns which has a kind
of an interesting look but that
jewel-like
for now lens looks almost otherworldly
it looks like a spaceship or an alien
life-form and I and so that put us in
the second half of the 19th century and
then I also wanted the foghorn which put
us even which then if I wanted the right
White House station to look around down
I'd like the
I could place us was like what was about
1890 and I must say that this lighthouse
station is unrealistically run down the
like the United States light
establishment was run like a military
organization and Defoe would have been
fired long ago for the lighthouse in
such disrepair but we sort of invented
the idea that this lighthouse is so
remote that the lighthouse inspectors
never bothered to go there interesting
so the the whole concept of him making
sure that his colleague keeps everything
like polished is and it's very accurate
that's accurate yeah but it's funny that
he's constantly cleaning this place and
it never right quality in actuality I'd
like please these lighthouse inspectors
become and they would come unannounced
and check everything out and and they
would you know they would ring the bell
of the ship put up the flag and everyone
would panic and put on their uniforms
and you know polish their buttons to
make sure that they were ready for the
inspector like a health inspector in a
restaurant that's great yes and I know
when we spoke one interview about the
making the which you mentioned that you
have a great fondness for Shakespeare
and so what was very important for you
is that your character spoken the serve
the knack Euler at the time and that's
clearly the case here as well but what
sort of research did you do to make sure
that you know that their language was
was accurate weird where you books do
you read to final this I mean the we
began my brother I began with Melville
do England maritime classics and and I
mean we looked at all kinds of stuff and
and there's like lots of dictionaries
and thesauruses and glossaries about
sailor terminology but finally
I mean and we look to interviews with
lighthouse keepers and lighthouse
keepers journals and interviews with
Lumberjacks and what but but the the
most helpful source was the writings of
a Maine based author from this period
named Sarah Orne Jewett and she would
interview very working people and write
her stories in dialect
and so her seafaring characters are sort
of how'd the fellow speaks and and the
farmers and stuff is more how prop
speaks I mean it's a synthesis of a lot
of things but she was became the most
helpful and my wife found a woman who
did who's a little in star Cutler wrote
her thesis on dialect into it and she
broke down the dialects and provided
rules which was amazing because when I
when I've written things in the 19th
century that haven't been made for there
are more like posh English people there
are resources I can turn to with rules
there were because the which was the
time of Shakespeare there's resources
that provide rules before you know
working people's dialects it was very
lucky to have found to have found that
you know and for your actors who
obviously don't have the time to do as
much research as you done what's the
shortcut for them after they sign on
board I know you in the which you gave
each of your actors difference of prep
materials research materials right so
they could understand how the farming
community at the time worked and lived
so yeah yeah yeah I gave them each
different things and and documentaries
about lighthouse keepers and and I gave
I gave Rob a lot more research than
Willem Willam kind of felt like the
character was sort of there on the page
and it was mainly the
the dialect work for him but I gave him
see Shane
geez I gave him I gave him a lot of
stuff but I gave Rob quite a lot of
material to create a backstory with if
he wanted to and he likes to do that
late like that kind of work I think it's
more important to his process than it is
for Williams so you kind of you know
yeah so let's talk about the location
which is absolutely stunning
like how much location work is there I
think I know some of the answers to this
and how much did you have to build let's
talk about the design and you use your
same production designer right Craig
laughter Rob yep yep Craig Craig Lathrop
and he's he's with me again on the
Northmen making like villages and stuff
yeah I mean we we built every building
in the film we that was I mean that's
what I wanted to do from the beginning
but this was an expensive
black-and-white movie so I we took every
effort to try to find like a lighthouse
station or a White House Tower or
something that we could start with and
then build the rest but there was
nothing that served our story needs that
was accessible plenty of lighthouses
that would have worked really well for
us but they were in real-life places
like you know the pilot rock which it's
never named in the movie movie but
that's what it's called and so we needed
a place with road access and bad weather
where we could build a lighthouse and so
on the southern tip of Nova Scotia on a
place called Cape horseshoe that's part
of a fishing community called Yarmouth
we we found our location an inhospitable
Rock with great road access so we built
we built everything all the exteriors
are are there we built the the shed is
also we shot on four shoe and then much
of the scenes in late the galley in the
kitchen those were shot
for shoe as well but the rest of the
interiors were shot on a stage or you
know converted warehouses or what what
airplane hangars and stuff in Halifax I
mean the lighthouse tower interior you
have to you had to do on set no matter
what because we have scaffolds that's
holding up the tower so that it can
survive gale force winds and then so
there's there's no there's nothing yeah
there's nothing in there
and then additionally you need to be
able to pull walls out because the
diameter of the interiors is 8 feet so
so like it's not about cheating it's
about like physically getting a camera
and crew to like be in the space you
know you brought some material to share
with us right from some design I mean so
these are more elaborate than to look
books that I first show the the you know
people who might be financing the film
but these are the things that I make for
my crew so that we can be on the same
page and look for the same stuff the
title treatment for this is a little
different than the one that we finally
ended up with but is it this is a look
book that you carried with you earlier
so that everyone on your team could kind
of grasp your vision but also finances
so something similar to this they saw
something that was like a lot shorter
and a lot and and more about mood and
atmosphere as well this is this is like
this is for my collaborators but I
showed it to the studio too and they're
interested and you know it makes it look
like I know what I'm doing so here are
some lighthouse tenders you know ours
was from about 1912 what we found of
course we shoot it so wide that it
really
could have been CG perhaps but but but
we had the real thing which was which
was nice
here are some examples of some
lighthouse stations that ours is based
on these are all in in New England you
can see on the upper right hand corner
they're very large foghorn and that that
kind of extreme style like down below
that in Portland head light house
there's as much smaller foghorn from a
slightly later period which is it's not
quite as great obviously these look like
stills from your movie
that's how authentic your film looks
it's incredible well that's that's crazy
that's great the house on the bottom
left with the long flat structure is
called a breezeway which we did not
intend to have a very long breezeway the
movie but the the geography of Cape 4xu
made it so that we needed this
incredibly long breezeway and it became
kind of a fun detail here are some
lighthouse beacons with the same size
lens as ours one thing that the weather
vane that we have is actually more a
European thing and it's not goes very
common on lighthouses in New England but
it was a story beat that I liked and
it's not was important you know texture
we've you know we have you know Wyeth
paintings are a big part a big reference
for archetypal New England so I mean
he's sometimes he's kind of played out
but but he you know he's important
reference to know that we're on track
the the cistern that we ended up doing
is a little bit more sophisticated in
these big wooden buckets but that was
the original idea but the production
designer Craig encouraged me to do a
brick cistern that was porridge Dover
with a kind of plaster here's the
boathouse
runner is to go out to the sea which
which again like you know part of me and
my brother has researched what we've saw
kept seeing this these bow house with
these along runners in our research we
thought like we gotta build a scene
around that because that's that's cool
and and so we did the OL where there's a
film still I try not to do too many
stills or other movies try to keep their
research about life but there's a still
from through a glass darkly on the
bottom there in the the the the
shipwreck boat just to convey a little
bit of atmosphere that I that I liked
although that lighting is more polished
than anything we do in our movie signal
house I had my taking fistula I can flip
through it a little more quickly but you
get the idea you're referencing a lot of
Bergman in this right for sure
referencing this of taking some
inspiration from Big Time I mean all of
the all of his films on four are a big
influence on this movie for sure for
sure so knows well alright yeah yeah
which yeah which yeah
and again these these are really helpful
because it just saves a lot of
discussion you know that's that's the
cast-iron pot that's the pipes that's
the chair that's you know and you can
kind of you know keep things simple but
sometimes you can't find the stuff and
sometimes the designers push us further
so I had this roll top desk and in the
set decorator thought that that was
while they very much existed in New
England that they say like the Wild West
to people and and I said oh you you're
right
like let's see what else we can do maybe
can we find a bucket top desk you know
whatever anyway the desk he found is is
beautiful and very unique and transport
even much better than my suggestion so
as much as I do
oriented you know I can be persuaded
otherwise by better ideas yeah I mean
for people who are not sort of don't
think visually something like this is
really really helpful for them to grasp
your the concepts and your vision for
sure so of course like you know the
people in the art department like should
be able to think visually like yeah but
the simpler version of this you know
yeah when you show this to like I mean I
had this kind of elaborate lookbook for
the witch before it was financed which
was very helpful in people finally
financing it and I'll just quickly run
through sorry that I don't know the
keystrokes for everything you know the
characters are called young and old in
the screenplay and the entire time we
shot the film and all through through
posts but that was just because it was
just for clarity's sake okay well did
you have a team so saying all this
during the research or did you pull a
lot of it yourself no this is on me
Wow
you know that's like that's not that's
not entirely true some of some of the
some of the the buildings were things
that Craig had found in in his research
and of course
Craig finds a lot more research and
Linda the closet designer finds a lot
more research on top of the research
that I do but like you know but but it
starts out like this but but yeah I'd
sit like this this is documents all my
research and I'd say that that
production design is you know 95 percent
stuff that I found so yeah so those are
the kinds of things I make Wow on this
new movie the scale is so huge that
while I do do like I I did make like a
very like elaborate lookbook where I
combine costumes and and sets but
there's so many different more locations
and so many different things that like
I'm like I the scale is so large that I
cannot literally do every single like
know every single prop like myself
before I bring my collaborators on to
come together so that's been a challenge
with the with the new movie is like but
but but I trust Craig and Linda so much
that once we are doing approvals it's
very rare that I'm not like you know
excited and and by what they've done and
their collaborators have done I came
back to the lighthouse quickly you
mentioned you wanted a location with
terrible weather how much how much did
you have to control the weather I like
just sort of with like rain machines and
stuff and how much of it was real how
much did you fake with effects yeah I
mean I'd say it's about 50/50 I'd say
that most of the most dramatic weather
is is real a lot of times it's it was
just sort of soft rain
was faked but certainly you know the
giant waves hitting the lighthouse tower
were like dump trucks and water and
water cannons and when they launched the
boat into the you know into the ocean
like the you know it was it was really
raining it was really windy but like
again those waves were made by us so
that we wouldn't lose Robert Pattinson
to a Riptide or whatever yeah how do you
prepare your actors first such grueling
conditions I mean they are up for I mean
you know Robin Defoe choose challenging
material and they knew what they were
getting themselves into so I mean it
wasn't easy and it wasn't always fun
exactly but but you know as Willem says
you don't have to act it if it's
happening to you well yeah I was
wondering like if there are other things
to help him get into that headspace did
they I mean they spend time together
beforehand we had a rehearsal period
together and we also they also you know
went to the White House and they checked
it out Willem lived in a little
fisherman's cottage very close to the
location actually so he was always like
sent me marinated in the world so he's
like that you know waking up to making a
fire a lot kind of stuff yeah and let's
talk a little bit about the seagulls the
seagulls are amazing they're they're the
most stubborn animals on the best of
days
do you have trained seagulls we did she
goes in England where all the
classically trained actors are yeah so
the the like outside of London there's a
a French guy who is really great with
birds he did the Alice for Harry Potter
and basically these three seagulls are
were injured and rehabilitated and they
can't survive in nature so you know they
they're trained to do tasks which is
kind of what keeps them from being too
depressed so so there they were great
they were really really really very
talented those three birds that do all
the seagull work - so did you shoot that
in England oh did you did you fly no no
we we shot that in Pinewood okay is some
of that fight then so it's in yeah movie
magic a little bit but how you shoot a
seagull in Pinewood and then insert it
into an image shot in Nova Scotia
yeah I've been reluctant to be to talk
about this in such detail but it's it's
fine I mean whatever it does it doesn't
matter
basically we shot Rob shot his scenes
with a puppet and that puppet barely
makes its way into the film but but
there was a puppet that did all the
scenes with Rob and then we would shoot
a plate without a seagull in it and then
we would you know do very do do sort of
stuff for to record the lighting
conditions so then we like rebuilt
portions of the set in Pinewood and shot
the bird the birds in Pinewood and and
then put and then you know put them in
to the movie so how was your production
in total it was about 35 days in in Nova
Scotia plus three or four days of
seagulls and one short day of of logs in
Brooklyn the
the the yeah so so some of the some of
the log sequence in the beginning the
dream where the lumberjack is is washed
up was done in a warehouse close to my
old apartment in Brooklyn and then post
takes place where also in New York okay
yeah
and how much I mean how much visual
effects other like by some inserting
that see girls in other some visual
effects you did uh yeah I mean there's
the usual kind of clean up stuff that
happens on movies of this budget these
days which is a shame but I just kind of
how it is and you know I mean obviously
that means the last shot if we only have
three signals like you know that's
obviously gonna take a lot of visual
effects and but you know it's mainly
like erasing stuff it's mainly erasing
harnesses because when they're like
standing on the edge of a cliff they're
like wearing a harness when when you
know there's an additional harness when
Rob's whitewashing this side of the
lighthouse that needed to be erased
there's safety boats that need to be
erased there's it's like it's a lot of
erasing right but most of us have
elements the nature's elements that are
in the shots with sharp in-camera where
possible yeah why also even if even if I
am doing like some comp work I want to
shoot the real things I don't want to
make stuff in CG yeah we're almost time
for some questions we have a lot of
questions coming up anyone who hasn't
asked a question can I use the questions
tab and I'll try to get to as many of
these as possible
so yeah the film debuted a can it one
for press T Award right and yeah has
gone on to like I think all nominations
to Spirit Award wins and an Oscar
nomination for your DP it's been amazing
the response
how do you feel about that the people
really have embraced it a movie about
like late 19th century my housekeepers
going crazy
I mean it's I'm grateful I'm humbled and
relieved I mean there was a lot of
pressure with the witch and I was like
quite terrified it can and and in a 24
and of all movies not go well it can in
the past they all told me all about how
terrible don't go well and I was I was
quite frightened but none of course of
course it's incredibly gratifying when
people understand what you're doing I
mean it's it's it's a lot of work to
make a movie so tell us a little bit
about the project you're working on now
what you can tell us
I mean what's been reported is that it's
a Viking revenge saga it takes place at
the turn of the 10th century some of it
takes place in in Iceland and yeah I
mean it's it's it's a lot it's it's it's
a lot of fun it's I'm digging myself
into holes with the same problems of
animals and boats and things that like
you should never do and more
inhospitable locations but but that's ok
I have I have my all my heads of
department back with me which is
incredibly fun it was also like we went
into this very quickly after the
lighthouse so that felt really good
so the hiatus happened that felt
particularly not so good but yes I'm a
bean pie but perhaps I can be prodded
with questions or we can move on to you
collaborating with shown how to
pronounce his name
Tsun is a an Icelandic novelist and poet
who's really quite incredible we met at
a cocktail party and I didn't know him
didn't know his work and he said I said
so I understand you're a writer like
what do you do and he's like well I just
finished a book about witchcraft didn't
17th century Iceland and I thought oh
cool you know so we talked a lot that
evening and then of course so then I
went home and I read some of his work
and I thought really this guy is
incredible
so while Noah is going to you know throw
tomatoes and stones at me for you know
appropriating Nordic culture I still
wanted you know a real Viking to write
this Viking saga with me and Iceland is
popular these days I'm sure everyone
knows this but you know but but really I
cylinders have this connection to to
this Viking past likes young can tell
you the the saga figures that he's
directly related to and and there is
it's it's it's there was aspects of
Viking culture that remain in
contemporary culture there so and seoane
is I mean if I can move you know like a
movie he's a great writer and a great
collaborator yeah I've never heard of
him until if you recommended the Blue
Fox to me which I loved but then I read
in more about him and he's known here
for collaborating with Bjork quite a bit
right yep yep for sure I'm working some
of the songs from dance from the dark
and has an Oscar nomination yes yeah so
yeah oh okay this guy some questions
here Chris is asking about your new film
you mentioned you have been prepared
prepping for a film for the last five
months what does that prep process
entail
and what does that look like daily uh
frankly I've never written so many
emails in my entire life I feel like I'm
just I was just like in the office
writing emails all day much to my
chagrin but you know there's many
locations in the film so we're
constantly going on Scouts or as they
call them over here rec ease to like
find places or reassess places that
we've found and we're building sets
there so we're taking things out and
rethinking things out understanding how
we can you know once you put the
buildings there that's where they're
gonna be and you have to make sure that
that you can shoot all your scenes in
that location with the buildings in that
way you know we're designing all these
worlds we're building all these villages
we're making thousands of costumes
making all the props training the horses
to do the things the horses need to do I
mean everything I mean everything
designing the shots of the film so
there's a lot more storyboarding I
generally I I only like I prefer I mean
the past I preferred to shot lists and I
enjoy and I would storyboard the scenes
that had visual effects animals stunts
things we're all like we're all the
different departments who really need to
be on the same page for them for it to
work out but this movie like there's
rarely a scene that isn't on a boat or
has a lot of extras or you know whatever
so so we are storyboarding most of the
film and so that's taking a lot of time
as well and that's something that we're
continuing to do now on this hiatus
right you told me I think before we
started that you were the lockdown came
like a week before you was meant to
start shooting yeah we were you know
most of the actors were there we had
begun rehearsals we were doing hair and
makeup and costume
tests we was very close
but there are other things that are
continuing now they continue like making
yeah very a small crew that is still
working from home on certain things
there's an armor to armors are working
from home making armor for lead
characters there there are prosthetics
being made there's you know I'm doing my
work with the DP in the storyboard
artist there are things that need to be
happening I mean the location manager
Naomi's constantly having to check on
all of our locations that are you know
sitting with semi built sets you know um
so Ryan says do you write your scripts
with the traditional idea of the
protagonist having a goal that they
actively pursue throughout the story it
doesn't seem like the lighthouse has
this yeah that is definitely not the
light I mean the lighthouse you know to
be self-deprecating but quite honest
like is the same scene over and over and
over again only slightly different if
you're looking for like you know good
traditional narrative storytelling like
this is not the movie for you for sure
this is but but you know I said like you
know sometimes you're in the mood from
for Mary Poppins and sometimes you're in
the mood for Lost Highway but yeah and
it's been fun working at the Northmen
which is has a central protagonist with
a very clear goal and and to need to do
storytelling that's incredibly clear and
where clarity is helping is is is
helping I know that sounds like an
obvious thing but certainly for the
lighthouse you know a lot of the work
was trying to obscure things there are
versions of the script that my brother
and I found were too clear and but we
want the intention is for the audience
to become to go mad and become confused
like Winslow
and be putting it together as they as
they go and thrown off course so so that
was done with with care but no I mean
Rob's character doesn't know what he
wants that's kind of like his problem so
that's you know but that's isn't that
how many of us are in life yeah but
again that generally doesn't make for
like a super compelling story so I I get
it when I from Jesse when I saw a
lighthouse I thought there surprisingly
funny and it times reminded me of the
work of Neil Simon at what point in your
process did you start adding humor to it
and why from from the beginning I
especially you know I had I had the
which hadn't got made but I had written
it version of it and I so I wanted to
explore something that was going to be
able to laugh at misery instead of just
be miserable to sort of contrast the
witch so it started with farting from
from the from the beginning although Rob
and Willem are such good comedians I was
concerned it was going to be too funny
when we were shooting the film but we
found we were able to find the tone
through sound design and edit what
program do you make your look books in
says Tara and Devin says you do look
books for post departments as well such
as like sound design would that be a
sound book listen book I like that idea
I've never done that but I think I
should do that I mean certainly I share
like examples of stuff that I like this
like the sound of with the sound
designer but it's usually a little bit
less organized than these look books I
just do honestly I just use pages you
know when I sometimes for the when I
heard for a lookbook that I'm pitching I
will use like Photoshop and InDesign
make something that I can have more
control over and can be like really
polished and professional but these are
more sort of internal things and and so
pages is easy following on on that kind
of on the same lines Matthew says 8:24
created a beautiful screenplay book for
the witch as well as Mac in a moonlight
do you know if they're going to do one
for the lighthouse I hope so but I don't
take their whole process and I really
they did yeah
Caitlin says hi Robert do you have a
favorite memory from working on the set
of the lighthouse the most memorable day
of shooting for example love you and
your films thank you for being here
thank you for the continent there's so
many days I mean shooting the mermaids
swimming was pretty crazy because she
couldn't walk around in her tail and so
they had like we shot that in a in a
large tank in and how facts were they
trained emergency divers and so she was
in this like just kind of looked like an
Egyptian sarcophagus kind of you know
tail and they put I stood her up on a
crane and then like lowered her into
like into an inflatable pool full of hot
water where she was sitting inside this
larger tank and it was just you know I
was that was that was weird but I mean
there was I mean so many so many
memorable things I mean the food to foe
as the sea god that was it was it was a
it was a crazy shoot I I you know we did
it would I don't know how does a moment
what is how does mermaid get around
between shots like just everyone brings
stuff to her yeah I mean we'll really
she was carried around like either like
on this crane or on a beer when she was
when she when we did the scene on the
beach they were carrying her other beers
like a like a kind of like a stretcher
like out to the beach yeah Nancy asks
can you talk about your writing process
please that's right yeah I mean I mean I
could direct you to a lecture that I did
on my writing process that's on on
YouTube I'm sure you can find it but but
it's you know it's you know it's
researched based and and that's fun for
me because it gives me a lot of freedom
because it's easy to find the
inspiration I don't usually get writer's
block because I can kind of pick up a
book and write something might not be
good but at least I'm continuing to to
write so that's pretty vague but but
there's there's there's certainly stuff
out there where I couldn't it's more
detailed the zaiba asks if how did Chris
Columbus get involved with witch in the
White House George that's just the sign
of its for George asking about yeah so
we as so many many indie movies do we
kind of ran out of financing because one
of our financers backed out with the
witch so we were kind of doing posts
with monopoly money and we needed to
finish the movie and we screened the
film for Chris Colombo Columbus and his
daughter Eleanor who have maiden voyage
that helps out first the second time
filmmakers and you know they liked it
and they helped out and then Chris has
been a great mentor ever since and and
you know and he found us those seagulls
so thanks Chris
Jack Jake asks how much did your access
stick to the script and whether any bits
of improvisation especially considering
the specific language of the film no I
mean you know Mike Lee there's probably
other people but Mike Lee is the only
director that I know of who like
workshops a period movie with this kind
of specific dialogue and dialect to be
able to you know have actors be able to
improvise like that you know the
rehearsal period was a week there B
would be completely impossible for them
to improvise the dialogue so anything
that's not the same as the script was a
you know an accident
look people asking for sort of
recommendations or some inspirations
Kaitlyn says you've made to the best
horror movies in the last decade what
are some of your personal all-time
favorite horror films from one for a
fanatic to another i mean clearly the
shining is like overly influenced by the
shining alien is is great.i I you know I
love German Expressionism and Hammer and
Universal horror movies and stuff this
canonical 80s movies I was too afraid of
as a kid and I didn't see a lot of them
until much later so I was sort of too
old to to appreciate them and they're
they're they're like I don't have it
there I don't have nostalgia around them
and so I kind of see them as not so
awesome although I Hellraiser was pretty
cool which I did which I you know only
saw a few years ago embarrassingly but
yeah
a j-class tiny feet of film was shot for
the lighthouse
I do not know that question I wish that
I did but more than the producers wish
we had tell you that um Christian about
the witch from Adam can you elaborate on
the process of directing the young boy
for his death scene in the witch well
that was that was tough and it was very
collaborative
Ralph Anson and Kate Dicky who played
the parents were were very helpful I for
whatever reason I just didn't have the
greatest chemistry with with Harvey and
in the beginning
Harvey played Caleb I think he was more
of like a lad and like into playing you
know football / soccer for both but I'm
like my son's willing to talk and we've
been in the UK forever and we're gonna
be here for a lot longer and then post
is in London so I'm like should I be
telling in football instead of soccer so
I'd be telling him trousers instead of
pants like I guess I should so anyway so
anyway ralph was kind of saying you need
to direct him like a coach like a sports
coach and and that was very helpful but
then we also knew that like Harvey
couldn't understand the sexual aspects
of what he was doing would be
inappropriate his age and and it would
also have just like shut him down like
even if even if even if even if we were
appropriate which it wouldn't have been
it would have said them down so so it
was a lot it was kind of like a dance
you know and when we talked about him
being very thirsty and like needing to
learn like and touching his lips because
they're very dry but he's parched and
trying to look for ways around you know
him dying in this semi orgasmic way and
and we also and we also knew that that
scene had to
or the rest of the movie was not gonna
work so that was rehearsed in the hotel
like you know we were her stood a lot
together but then Ralph and Kate drilled
this scene over and over again like all
the weekends with Harvey so yeah and
then on set I was a football coach I
guess you could say Jay coughs how many
drafts of the lighthouse did you write
that's a good question I don't know a
lot probably I mean I think there is
only three or four external drafts but
you know it takes many you know many
internal drafts to get to a draft that
you share with other people so but but
there was about four I think that that
were published so to speak it took a
long time to figure out what the hell we
were doing so do you stick closely to a
storyboard when you are shooting or do
it allow yourself to improvise shots on
the set because I'm after a level of
craft that I can't have with my level of
experience
gerrae and I tend to kind of stick to
what we planned
i sir so just so that we can make our
day and and we think a lot about it
before we commit to something that said
being really prepared can prepare you
sometimes to come up with something
better but if it is it's rarely much
different it's really much different
Claire asked I'm working on a project
set in the nineteenth century could you
please share some dialog resources the
characters range from working class to
upper class
yeah I mean I think you know there's
there's if you google 19th century
slang dictionary and Victorian I mean it
depends on where it's set of course but
but I also you know and and and but if
you google those dictionaries you can
find them easily I don't have my books
here I would show you some covers of
things that would be helpful but also
you know look look at trying to find
books that are in your period published
in the period written in the period that
take place where your story takes place
and look for turns of phrase and and and
and write it down
question from teria what was your
approach for the music well originally I
wanted no strings because the which was
so string heavy but mark Corvin the
composer but was like you're gonna want
some strings and and there's plenty
strings in the movie but I wanted it
only to be horns and pipes and and thing
things that felt like the sea and like
Willem Dafoe's farts and like the
foghorn and then and that's most of
what's what's going on there but and but
but we needed something that kind of
also because because the score within
the beginning was quite experimental and
and weird and would have made a nice
experimental album but it wasn't quite
suiting the film and we needed something
that did match the fact that it looked
like a black and white old-timey movie
to some extent so there we have these
sort of bernard herrmann desk string
passages that I think help kind of tie
everything together sometimes they're on
the
to the point of like tongue-in-cheek but
I think it's it was needed one how many
directors have said I want my music to
sound like Windham defies farce we're
almost out of time we find a question
for everyone on our roll one and if from
Mido as well who's asking kind of
recommendations for reading what you
read and read for inspiration but also
just what are you watching right now you
know what is what should everyone should
check out it can be like a forgotten
classic Sunday like a hidden gem look
just dig as deep as you like yeah I mean
I I mean I read for whatever I'm working
on you know for pleasure
I like Mac and in Blackwood and mr.james
stuff like that but but and but and also
lots of comparative mythology and
comparative religion but you know right
now I've been reading a lot of Viking
sagas and Viking books you know so but I
you know I recommend the sagas if you're
also the Johanna Catrin 3/3 daughter
who's one of the advisers on the film
that's another one of the best things
about working on it movie this size is
that I like reached out to my so my
favorite Viking historians and my
favorite Viking asourian's and they just
said yes no one I reached out to like
said no so I'm working with these
incredible historians which is like one
of the most fun inspiring things ever
finally johanna wrote a book Valkyrie to
get on Amazon and anywhere you buy books
which is sort of the the most up-to-date
book about female experience in the
Viking Age and I highly recommend
but but yeah as far as films I got a
bunch of box sets of failing lopoliths
the Greek director I've only seen some
of his work and I've been kind of going
through that in this period and I also
was such a snob when I was in my in my
early days that I missed out on a lot of
really good Kurosawa because yeah I
really I really liked like Ron and
throne of blood and Rashomon and
Kagemusha and a few others I really
appreciated but like the more fun ones
like yo Jimbo and Sandro and hidden
fortress like I've kind of totally
thought that they were too goofy when I
was like really getting to know Kurosawa
but I watching those in the Criterion
channel and I missed
I really missed out being such a snob
hidden fortress was the biggest
inspiration for Star Wars right yep yeah
but I mean you know you see it and you
you know it's mainly like those there's
some things but it's not you know have
you seen my and lo I have my favorites
yeah it's great but of course knowing
like I prefer all the like this is you
know more the older the better you know
like in the time period you know feudal
Japan yeah that's more fun for me plus
in with doing the Viking stuff it's like
you know I'm looking at staging horses
and sword fights and blah blah blah
well I think we're out of time but thank
you so much for spending the hour with
us Robert good luck with your Viking
epic I hope it gets back into production
soon yeah before your son start speaking
with a Belfast accident and hopefully
you'll come back and join us when it's
over when it's complete and they're out
in cinemas so
please take care and stay safe this has
been a coffee talk filming a pendant
check out more from us at film
independent dog we're back with another
coffee talk next week that from me Paul
cowling say goodbye thank you and Robert
Eggers thank you so much Robert
thanks Ruby see you soon
[Music]